the world's financial market place's
engine houses of wealth drivers of
capital growth and still even after the
crisis of 2008 places of rotten practice
insider trading and market manipulation
billions of automated transactions
performed in nanoseconds make
malpractice all the more doable these
days in Europe different laws and non
sanctions make such malpractice all the
more escapable until today step up
Arlene McCarthy lead MEP in Parliament's
efforts to harmonize surveillance and
punishment with a serious deterrence for
traders and their companies committing
market abuse and manipulation including
hefty prison sentences this will be my
last legislate in this Parliament and so
it's a real privilege for me to be able
to work on this very important dossier
to ensure that those intent on
committing market abuse can be sent to
jail in all 28 member states the most
obvious candled come to light was the
LIBOR benchmark rate fix in which
traders manipulated interest rates set
on a daily basis so as to benefit from
trades has affected mortgages if it's
affected loans that people have taken
I'd I mean interest rates are the
fundamental lynchpin of how you
determine prices and costs I believe
that the public consumers want us to see
us being tougher if you have the
prospect of a jail sentence for cleaning
this offends it is a big deterrent I'm a
sensitive either the global financial
crisis erupted we thought well now the
financial sector will get back to
behaving sensibly in a way and morally
that unfortunately has not happened
still today there are some countries
that consider deal insider dealing as a
kind of you know gentleman's offense but
but not as a criminal act now we have to
overcome this important to according to
some Emmy ps4 the healthy functioning of
the single market if we do not have
effective European legislation
surveillance harmonized level of our
sanctions this is something that we
leave totally after the value-based the
moves passed by a huge majority helping
MEP say tourists
public confidence in the financial
markets the Guardians and after all of
most people's money